UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT SAID THERE
IS ALMOST NO LIFE LEFT IN THE
BESIEGED TOWN OF SOLID AIR,
CAPTURING THAT TOWN WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER FOR RUSSIAN FORCES TO
SURROUND AND ULTIMATELY SEES
NEARBY BAKHMUT, GIVING RUSSIA A
MUCH-NEEDED WIN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, THIS FIGHT FOR
SOLID OUR IS ELUCIDATING SOME
UNUSUAL PRAISE FOR UKRAINE FROM
THE CHIEF OF RUSSIA'S PRIVATE
MILITARY CONTRACTORS, SCOTT
MCLAIN BACK WITH US THIS HOUR
FROM KYIV.
AND, IT IS THE WAGNER CHIEF
SUGGESTING THAT UKRAINIANS, IN
SOLID OUR, ARE FIGHTING WITH
HONOR, IT DOES SEEM REMARKABLE
TO HEAR THAT FROM THE CHIEF OF
THEM.
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO ACTUALLY
BE HAPPENING?
WE ARE GETTING DESCRIPTIONS
FROM BOTH SIDES.
IT IS CLEAR WHAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING ON ON THE GROUND?
>> BECKY, BOTH SIDES WILL TELL
YOU THAT THE FIGHTING IS
EXTREMELY INTENSE THERE, BEYOND
THAT THERE ARE SOME CONFLICTING
VIEWPOINTS ON WHAT IS HAPPENING,
IF YOU ASK THE HEAD OF THE
DONETSK PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC ONE
OF THE OCCUPIED TERRITORIES IN
UKRAINE, HE SAYS THAT SOLID ARE
IS ALMOST CAPTURED, BUT HE DID
NOT OFFER ANY EVIDENCE TO THAT.
UKRAINIANS SAY DON'T COUNT THEM
OUT JUST YET, WE ARE JUST GOT
WORD A FEW HOURS AGO FROM
UTILITY CRANIAL MILITARY SANE
SITUATION IN THE TOWN IS STABLE,
EVEN BETTER THAN STABLE, IN
SOME PARTS ALONG THE FRONT LINE
IN AND AROUND BAKHMUT, BUT THEY
ALSO DID NOT RULE OUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF WITHDRAWING OR
RETREATING, TROOPS FROM SOLID,
ARE THEY SAID THAT IF THEY DID
THAT THAT WOULD, THE PRIMARY
REASONING OR FACTORING INTO
THAT DECISION WOULD BE THE
LIVES OF THEIR TROOPS.
SO THAT THEY COULD LIVE TO
FIGHT ANOTHER DAY AND LIFE TO
TRY TO RETAKE THIS TERRITORY.
BUT, AS I SAID, THE ACADIANS
NOT MINCING WORDS, PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY DESCRIBE THE FIGHTING
THERE AS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT,
IT SEEMS CLEAR THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE AMASSED A HUGE
NUMBER OF TROOPS IN A VERY
LARGE VOLUME OF WEAPONS AND
EQUIPMENT ALONG THE FRONT LINES
OF SOLID ARE.
HOPING THAT THEY CAN CAPTURE
THAT CITY AND THEN START
ATTACKING A BAT MOVED FROM A
DIFFERENT ANGLE FROM THE NORTH,
BECKY.
>> YOU ARE IN THE CAPITAL, WHAT
IS THE VIEW FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY?
>> YES, WE GOT WORD TODAY FROM
THE RUSSIANS THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE RELEASING A LIST OF NAMES OF
VICTIMS FROM THAT DEVASTATING
STRIKE ON THE TEMPORARY
BARRACKS IN MAKIIVKA, THAT EVEN
THEY CONCEDED KILLED 89
SHOULDERS, CITING AND PART
PRIVACY REASONS, THERE IS ALSO
CONTINUED SHELLING IN THE
KHERSON REGION, MORE STRIKES IN
KRAMATORSK AND ALSO IN KHARKIV.
AND, I SHOULD WARN, YOU THE
PICTURES YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE,
SOME VIEWERS MAY FIND THAT THE
SERVING.
>> AMIDST THE DESTRUCTION THERE
IS MOVEMENT, AN UNLIKELY SIGN
OF SURVIVAL.
THEN, COMMOTION AS RESCUE CREWS
ARRIVE TO PULL THE VICTIM OUT.
A FEW FEET AWAY A POLICE
OFFICER WALKS OUT CARRYING AN
INJURED GIRL, WHO OFFICIALS SAY
IS JUST 13 YEARS OLD.
BLOODIED BUT ALIVE AND UKRAINE
SAYS THAT ON MONDAY A RUSSIAN
MISSILE STRIKE HIT A MARKET IN
THIS VILLAGE SOME 25 MILES FROM
THE FRONT LINE.
LOCALS OFFICIALS SAY THAT AT
LEAST TWO PEOPLE DIED AND SIX
OTHERS WERE HURT ON THE WEEKEND
WHEN THE RUSSIANS LAUNCHED A
SERIES OF MISSILE STRIKES IN
KRAMATORSK.
THEY SAY IT WAS IN RETALIATION
FOR A DEVASTATING NEW YEAR'S
STRIKE ON A RUSSIAN MAKESHIFT
BARRACKS.
EVEN RUSSIA CONCEDES IT KILLED
89 SOLDIERS THOUGH UKRAINE
INSISTS THERE WERE MANY MORE.
RUSSIA CLAIMS IT'S RETALIATORY
STRIKES CLAN KILLED MORE THAN
600 UKRAINIAN TROOPS, UKRAINE
CALLED THAT NONSENSE.
CNN'S TEAM IN THE CITY FOUND NO
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THERE HAD
BEEN A MASS CASUALTY EVENT.
JUST A MASSIVE CRATER IN FRONT
OF A HIGH SCHOOL AND A LOT OF
BROKEN GLASS.
SOME OF THE FIERCEST FIGHTING
IS TAKING PLACE IN BAKHMUT, AND
NEARBY SOLID ARE, A VISITING
UKRAINIAN GENERAL SAW THE
DESTRUCTION ALONG THE MAIN ROAD
AND THEY HIVE OF ACTIVITY AS
MEDICS WORKS TO TREAT AN
INJURED SOLDIER IN AN
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION.
NEAR BAKHMUT A UKRAINIAN DRONE
CAPTURED THE MOMENT A BOMB IS
DROPPED ON RUSSIAN TROOPS
CARRYING AN INJURED SOLDIER.
BOTH CAVE AND SOME RUSSIAN
MILITARY BLOGGERS BELIEVE
MOSCOW IS EYEING A FRESH ROUND
OF CONSCRIPTION TO BOLSTER THE
FRONT LINES, THE KREMLIN HAS
FIRMLY DENIED IT, THAT WOULD
ALSO DENIED ITS PLANS AHEAD OF
THE FIRST MASS MOBILIZATION IN
THE FALL.
ON SUNDAY 50 RUSSIAN PRISONERS
OF WAR WERE SWAPPED FOR 50
UKRAINIANS HELD CAPTIVE WITHOUT
ANY NEWS FROM THE BATTLEFIELD.
WHAT IS GOING ON ONE SOLDIER
ASKS?
IZIUM HAS BEEN LIBERATED, HE IS
TOLD.
IT WAS RECAPTURED WAY BACK IN
SEPTEMBER.
>> AND, BECKY, IN ADDITION TO
THE STRIKES ON KRAMATORSK THAT
I MENTIONED IN THAT STORY THERE
WAS YET ANOTHER MISSILE STRIKE
LATE LAST NIGHT THAT LANDED IN
THE CITY, THIS ONE LANDED ON A
ROADWAY AND KILLED TWO PEOPLE
WHO WERE INSIDE OF A CAR
NEARBY.
IT IS NOT CLEAR WHAT, IF ANY
KIND OF MILITARY TARGET THE
RUSSIANS WERE ACTUALLY AIMING
FOR.